Bryan Butler: Okay,
Bryan Butler: This is only going to be about a 30 minute talk, so we should have plenty time at the end for any kind of question discussion or what everyone else wants to talk to that after all of this,
Bryan Butler: And this is a project that i've worked on over the years and it keeps coming back so that's one of the reasons why I decided to bring this up with the marketing group i've been in and out of marketing groups for the past few years, and also work in marketing research,
Bryan Butler: and
Bryan Butler: So a little bit about me,
Bryan Butler: I am a manager of analytics data science at a small bank in Boston,
Bryan Butler: I started out in chemistry and then got an MBA that a lot of work in the insurance industry doing some pretty exotic stuff,
Bryan Butler: got heavily involved in Monte Carlo and pricing,
Bryan Butler: And then got involved in quantum banking consulting, so I think, as you can see, like every other data scientist, I just want the exact straight out of College into data science,
Bryan Butler: So we'll talk about here is what this project is all about, and then try to give it to you in a way, so that you can take this to your next marketing project,
Bryan Butler: talk a little bit about what good survey design is or what I think it is there's an interesting bit of intellectual property, the,
Bryan Butler: ability to work on called customer quotient similar in a way to NPS but also very different look at some parameters constraints men getting involved in machine learning part of how do you actually do machine learning with with survey data,
Bryan Butler: So,
Bryan Butler: The role of this was how do you how do you take a survey because that's what a lot of people in marketing research to,
Bryan Butler: and develop a segmentation engine out of it, so that, as people complete your survey, you can put them in the right segment, for whatever and you can segments can be based on whatever,
Bryan Butler: In this case, this was a sort of a behavioral psychographic segmentation, which means it wasn't so much you bought product, a B, or you live in this part of world or wherever this is more about how you feel and how you behave,
Bryan Butler: And so it gives you a little different approach to sort of different dimensions of marketing,
Bryan Butler: And it was looking to reveal this is again this is part of a much larger project how people view companies, you know another way to think about it is that at the end of the day, rates how customer centric a company is and that's how that's how the questions were sort of phrase,
Bryan Butler: So these are some of the things that i've learned about what makes a good survey, and these are just my these are my takeaways from from being involved in surveys and trying to apply machine learning and,
Bryan Butler: You know how do you get it, how do you ensure you get a lot of response etc So the first thing is, I want to go over like what is the survey design dancer,
Bryan Butler: And then you get to want to have some supporting questions so let's think of structurally that's what that's how we want to start it,
Bryan Butler: In the goal you shouldn't have more than three things you're trying to answer I just say one two is good, just in case you know you get you pick up some other ancillary information,
Bryan Butler: And these goals statements are binary So yes, knows,
Bryan Butler: My first experience was,
Bryan Butler: Dealing with a survey and people are like well how likely, are you to,
Bryan Butler: purchase from us again, and so you end up with these neutral, you know everybody's in the neutral range and it doesn't really help you out or What do you do when you get,
Bryan Butler: A handful at the positive and the negative and handful a neutral to drop them included with something else, so this sort of resolve that issue it's a simple, yes, no,
Bryan Butler: With that the sporting questions you want as few as you can get away with, but still get the information that you want, so you know I like to think, maybe between five and 10 questions,
Bryan Butler: If you start getting over 10 questions you're just getting too much you're asking for too much information and you'll find that people will drop out over time,
Bryan Butler: The flip side around it is in the marketing research world you do have the ability to pay people with pick your incentive Amazon gift card PayPal whatever else they will stay in for a longer knowing that if they finish it they'll get some money at the end,
Bryan Butler: And i've done a couple of the i've done many of both and there doesn't seem to be a difference in engagement as far as like you get different answers, if you pay people,
Bryan Butler: And then here's a key thing,
Bryan Butler: I, like my supporting question so we got our we got our one binary like now, instead of what how likely, are you to buy from me again is I have bought from you again, or I will buy from you again, yes or no,
Bryan Butler: And then we're going to ask a bunch of questions that support it,
Bryan Butler: And I think everybody's seen these strongly agree agree neutral, etc, I do not like that scale,
Bryan Butler: One you don't get as much variability in the modeling phase,
Bryan Butler: Whereas one to 10 gives you plenty of variability and I think if you go over more than 10 people don't know what the numbers mean,
Bryan Butler: And just as a little aside, I worked in the wine industry for a while and you know they have their hundred point wine scale, but the funny thing is 99 point whatever percentage of the wines are ranked between 80 and 100 so what they're really have is a 20 point scale,
Bryan Butler: And so they disguise it as a night as 100 point scale versus 20 point scale same thing here i'm time points will give you enough variability,
Bryan Butler: And then the other thing is, you know people always say Oh, we can ask a question, a different way to make sure that we don't have people gaming the system,
Bryan Butler: Maybe if you get this giant survey that are like a personality test or something like that, but that's a whole different animal here,
Bryan Butler: If you're surveying your customers they're not going to do the duplicates and if they start seeing that people have to be like this is a waste of time and it's also wasting your time to like every question matters,
Bryan Butler: And i've seen some other indices out there, where they have like,
Bryan Butler: They try to decompose like a net promoter score which into three indices and it's kind of like,
Bryan Butler: they're the three indices are so incredibly correlated that you just wasted two questions i'll be asking about the other indices when they're they're like 90% correlated so it's kind of like you really have one,
Bryan Butler: In the marketing world I know anybody who's worked in marketing started net promoter score it's kind of a hybrid because it because it does ask,
Bryan Butler: on a scale of one to 10, but you can also but, at the end of day you can make people binary is out of it, in fact, there is a you know people that score you,
Bryan Butler: Nine and 10 are your promoters six to eight your neutrals and five and below or your,
Bryan Butler: detractors and the score only works with promoters detractors so it's a very unique scale, but when you do NPS you should really ask you don't get into the wise,
Bryan Butler: And then, a good rule of thumb is to try to get about 1000 responses,
Bryan Butler: Because you can do some really good modeling I know, everybody thinks Oh, this is the world of big data I need 10,000 800,008 million no you don't and you need a well designed survey, and if you get close to 1000 responses, you will get a reasonable amount of information,
Bryan Butler: what's interesting about surveys, is that, if your questions are distinctive enough, then, even if you get smaller segments, you will be able to predict them so, for instance, you know,
Bryan Butler: segment one is questions 123 in the end, you know segment two is maybe a question three and question for, but then segment three is an oddball question question five, even if it comes out small and you get into this highly unbalanced,
Bryan Butler: Data scenario, the fact that questions for five is so unique, it will help, even with a prediction in an unbalanced situation because it's not random,
Bryan Butler: So a little bit about customer quotient this is developed by a colleague of mine at sea space in Boston criminal Austin,
Bryan Butler: And it talks and it builds on this customer this sort of how customer centric as your company and they asked questions from from the customers perspective and you build up the pyramid from you know relevance you're just in the game at that point,
Bryan Butler: Then we have a customer series questions around customer experience how well you do, then the better, you are, you get into openness and that begins to really unlock the doors,
Bryan Butler: Are you willing to have an honest and open two way dialogue with your customers,
Bryan Butler: empathy is really what changes the game, so when I when i've seen companies in the segments,
Bryan Butler: it's not till you do reasonably well if openness and get into empathy that you begin to really like we've grouped different,
Bryan Butler: Companies and segments, and everything else, and you see when you start reading up on the empty scores you begin to run away and become streaming well and the last one, is what we call emotional validation those are the people out there that are selling your product on the recommendations,
Bryan Butler: always talk about is you have two people you have two people having a conversation someone says, I need to get into,
Bryan Butler: smartphone and the first verse says good night home phone and the other person really doesn't say anything,
Bryan Butler: So your iPhone is your sort of emotional validation person and they'll they'll give you five reasons why you should get an iPhone or on the flip side they'll give you five reasons,
Bryan Butler: Why, you should get an android or whatever it is, but they are selling your product and it's called emotional validation,
Bryan Butler: Though is your ultimate customers, because they are doing your marketing when we find that people that score higher up there actually have to spend less,
Bryan Butler: In marketing and advertising over the long term, and it gives them better scores let's just a little bit of this intellectual property area in the space that it worked on here,
Bryan Butler: For those with traditional marketing backgrounds where you talk about the four p's and the three c's and all is so the fourth phase product price place and promotion,
Bryan Butler: The three c's are customer company and competition and what these do is sort of map various questions that help with a,
Bryan Butler: cq scoring you know into these different,
Bryan Butler: Traditional marketing buckets so that like when we when we talked about pitching this different companies, if I had a traditional marketer I get so yeah this this is your product piece is your price piece, and you can see, like price,
Bryan Butler: it's all from that customer point of view, the company appreciates my loyalty and that's literally how the question word it's an action word or I don't feel ripped off,
Bryan Butler: And you can see, most of these questions, and these are sort of,
Bryan Butler: paraphrases of it but we've we've made it action oriented and it's from the customer standpoint not I first is, if you think about a lot of surveys, is the company is asking do you, like us, you know,
Bryan Butler: Do we do a good job at this and things like that, whereas this whole framework really reverses around,
Bryan Butler: So let's talk about this, this project that we had clients best fishing number one had to be available next out and that happens, you know I wish I could just do it and walk down or something easy like that or a web APP but,
Bryan Butler: At the same time is it's workable what it does do is it changes the model,
Bryan Butler: Processing a little bit you know i'm not going to be able to run an extra boost or in that,
Bryan Butler: But at the same time, I may not need to and and there's a good way that I get around this down the road,
Bryan Butler: Our sample size was 900 not 1000 but that's fine,
Bryan Butler: So, like okay,
Bryan Butler: Probably only get I get about three or four segments out of this,
Bryan Butler: And part of this came out of is that a major company was,
Bryan Butler: Had a project with a major consulting company and they said, well, you have a eight distinctive segments, and it was like okay really so we're going to test out whether we really have eight distinctive behaviors,
Bryan Butler: By using this this survey,
Bryan Butler: And the initial step, and this was one of the things that we said,
Bryan Butler: This one did not have the dependent there,
Bryan Butler: And so that's why I want that's why I added it in early on, is a good survey has a binary outcome, so we had to create one or create some sort of segmentation outcome, the nice thing is survey questions on a one to 10 scale easy to work with,
Bryan Butler: If you think about it, if in the from the machine learning world as we go down the road,
Bryan Butler: we're not gonna have to Center scale or do any of that with the data it's already prepackaged and i'm the one to 10 scale,
Bryan Butler: And you know we're good whether we do,
Bryan Butler: Any kind of and we're going to do on supervised learning or supervised you're not going to have to reschedule all the data which makes it, which makes it Nice,
Bryan Butler: And when you do some of these things, and these ones, are you know my discussion with them,
Bryan Butler: You know what's good enough actors,
Bryan Butler: Are there penalties for you know false positives and false negatives like if we put the person in the wrong segment, you know how costly, is it to your business,
Bryan Butler: and
Bryan Butler: Should we add penalties if they are costly in one way or another,
Bryan Butler: And that would change a little bit of the modeling to we would add, we would actually add a cost matrix into it down the road if we had to,
Bryan Butler: But in this case there weren't too many big deals and they said, you know you give me 80% of the way you give me 80% of the right answers i'll be happy, I was like okay 85 that's where she for hopefully we can do better that's one of the things for me as I always like to be in the 90s,
Bryan Butler: But sometimes it doesn't always work out that way,
Bryan Butler: So here's our own roadmap here, and you can use this over and over like anytime any kind of survey work you do i've used this format,
Bryan Butler: For a lot of NPS modeling that i've done for various companies over time,
Bryan Butler: design and I survey, so we asked for for NPS people we asked that question, but then we asked him questions about customer service we asked him questions about pricing,
Bryan Butler: Other aspects of the business the see what what you're trying to do is figure out what drives that answer what drives that yes, no,
Bryan Butler: So then we're going to do some clustering I like hierarchical clustering it's easy visualization the scale is easy so we're going to,
Bryan Butler: Separate our responses to some different segments and clusters and then we're going to create a dummy variable for each one so you're so right, you know you're in segment one or you're not you're in segment two you're not you're in segment three or you know,
Bryan Butler: I think a lot of people will try to go straight to sort of a multi nomo model hey we're just going to predict what segment you're in right out of with one equation those require a lot of data so yeah if you're in one of these big data worlds and you've got 10 thousands of 50,000,
Bryan Butler: You could probably pull it off with 1000 simple binaries is going to be the way to go, so here's my little my little magic here, or what I first do is use the elastic net regression the Glenn net model or Glenda package by Trevor has erupted terranea,
Bryan Butler: It was designed for genomics it really will help you reduce dimensionality and it's extremely fast,
Bryan Butler: And I give you a little bit of more information on this,
Bryan Butler: The people that are familiar with, rich or last soul regression, this is the hybrid so a ritual attempt to,
Bryan Butler: squeeze down all your coefficients to make them very small and, alas, so we'll do is if there are multiple variables that are correlated the last oh pick one lady elements out now, the problem with lesser regression is you don't know why it made the decision,
Bryan Butler: Is it, you know, a function of the gradient descent or function of the order of the data you just don't know and they talked about it in their paper,
Bryan Butler: about that, whereas with the elastic net does, I have three variables that are correlated if there are statistically valid we leave them all, we leave all three in if they're just not statistically valid we pull them all out,
Bryan Butler: And so that's why it, how it gets your dimensionality reduction,
Bryan Butler: So then, this last step is all right, we got to go into excel now you probably could do elastic net maybe not an excel, but you can easily do a logistic regression,
Bryan Butler: And so what we're going to do is build out our template so when we get batches of scores we just run them through our worksheet worksheet would logistic regression in there and then it's going to use a voting method and it'll choose what segment nearing,
Bryan Butler: So the first thing is, we run this,
Bryan Butler: The elbow famous elbow plot use for customer calls within this some of the squares residuals,
Bryan Butler: And so what you got as number of clusters, they told me they had eight segments, so I went for up to eight clusters, or at least their consulting company did,
Bryan Butler: And what we're looking for is the bend in the plot, you can see, you get the elbow at about three or four, at which point then it all sort of flattens out so,
Bryan Butler: If I had a lot more data I probably would shoot for four clusters,
Bryan Butler: Given that it was only 900 respondents three would probably do the job, you can see the the some of the squares,
Bryan Butler: goes down, obviously the most pure one, two and three between three and four it's very little, and after tails off so that's why we're looking at that,
Bryan Butler: inflection point,
Bryan Butler: Somebody plot them all out visually we get three groups,
Bryan Butler: And this is a you know you can see in the hierarchical clustering,
Bryan Butler: That you get the divisions almost fairly cleanly between the blue block and the Green block,
Bryan Butler: And the green block and the red black and the other way to interpret this is the people in the blue block are very different from the people in the red red segment,
Bryan Butler: And there's some great Asians across the middle,
Bryan Butler: I use this plot a lot when I do,
Bryan Butler: text analytics because it's really fun, then, because what you're seeing is when you do this with text, as these people are saying one thing to say it's something similar to these guys,
Bryan Butler: But now it's getting different and then you get something really weird at the other end,
Bryan Butler: So I I like this plot from a visual standpoint any access the other access is sort of just the distance distance metric,
Bryan Butler: And, as I mentioned, because all of our questions for a one to 10 scale,
Bryan Butler: I didn't have to reach scale anything to make to be able to do this, cluster and yeah this is small,
Bryan Butler: And it may be difficult to predict, but it doesn't automatically mean that because I said, if there are certain questions that are answered by a handful of people in the group, but that may some markedly different,
Bryan Butler: Then you'll still be pretty good at predicting whether or not people are in there,
Bryan Butler: So this was when I overlay my cluster analysis across their eight segments, it was kind of interesting I was like,
Bryan Butler: Well, you may have eight segments, but you have three distinct behaviors within each segment and what I mean is that you know, there is this grouping here,
Bryan Butler: or call number one for now behavior one that seems to cut across all of them, with the exception of these this segment and we also have behavior to,
Bryan Butler: Those people in the in betweens but then this behavior number five stands out,
Bryan Butler: And it appears that this convenience store resellers segment is actually kind of small in general,
Bryan Butler: But, looking at those numbers it's pretty clear that we have,
Bryan Butler: You know, you can describe it two different ways, you can say we have eight segments, with three behaviors or you can say I actually have 24 segments so granted that I have this social couple there are actually three forms of social couples,
Bryan Butler: Now what one of the interesting things about looking at some of these segments is,
Bryan Butler: What about people that will be crossing over some of them like how do they specific How did the company specifically put them in each segment and can you move or will you move over time, like How long do you stay, a new mom,
Bryan Butler: And you know how are you say social Cup,
Bryan Butler: Some of these others are a little bit more static but,
Bryan Butler: We got a nice clean picture here so it's good we are elbow plot told us we have three or four segments,
Bryan Butler: And most likely three our hierarchical clustering came up with about three segments, and we can see it here,
Bryan Butler: So the size thing is so we have three segments three equations,
Bryan Butler: So here's what here's a little bit more on the elastic net and,
Bryan Butler: The reason why I use it is it's going to give me my upper bound or performance for accuracy in this case,
Bryan Butler: We because my goal is to get it down to a logistic regression with a couple of questions,
Bryan Butler: But if if my last night commits comes in only at 80% accurate on the rough before we even do any kind of dimensionality reduction,
Bryan Butler: Then, my logistic regression, is he going across my 80% threshold so that's going to be problematic down down the road,
Bryan Butler: And the way it works is you know you think about your logistic regression it's you're in segment one or not you're in segment two or not, and the probability or segment three or not,
Bryan Butler: And for each person you get three scores, and the highest score when so in this case the person this data point came back the probability in segment three was 90% it beats 55 and beats 21 therefore they get assigned a segment three,
Bryan Butler: verses I think when you think about traditional way of just using a single logistic regression you generally assign your probability of 50% and it's greater than 50 it's in that segment here we're using a little a an ensemble type approach and we're gonna we're gonna boat basically,
Bryan Butler: standard,
Bryan Butler: split training testing, so you know 900 data points that's me,
Bryan Butler: testing and 650 training it's not great it's not bad,
Bryan Butler: How do we do,
Bryan Butler: So here's, the first thing segment number one,
Bryan Butler: The last thing that regression near perfect,
Bryan Butler: Very little,
Bryan Butler: false positives false negatives,
Bryan Butler: Good split here so it's not so unbalanced that basically it's an easy guess,
Bryan Butler: it's just a nice 99,26 really good,
Bryan Butler: And what So you see down here when we did these to say i'm not going to sort of show you the same plot three different times,
Bryan Butler: And another key piece to look at is this there's no information 3,61 that is essentially your data split,
Bryan Butler: If the no information right, and this was 90 or point nine zero or something or higher than that which, when you get an imbalance data sets,
Bryan Butler: Then, then you know that 9599 well it's a good list but it's not as impressive versus were at 60 on a random guests, and you know, for their hundred percent accurate and you can see, we got 94% on this segment to an ad and this small second that's,
Bryan Butler: not surprised, we knew it was going to be some all segment we knew it was going to be a little more challenging,
Bryan Butler: But it's still for the client standpoint they're quite happy with what they were seeing initially,
Bryan Butler: This is a nice little variable important slot with the,
Bryan Butler: last minute model and you've got your questions ranked order of importance and when the when the,
Bryan Butler: plots out this way, that means they put you in the segment and you'll See you in another class they go the other way to say, and when you answer this question it gets you out of the segment,
Bryan Butler: And now there's others more sophisticated approaches out there there's line,
Bryan Butler: that's probably the most common now that people are using locally interpretive modeling,
Bryan Butler: But this one of the things that tells me now is I can begin to remove some of the questions from this equation right what i'm trying to do is make us,
Bryan Butler: simplify this as much as possible, so i'm going to say for segment one we're just going to use a couple of questions so that not only have three variables for this equation make perfectly easy simple for, especially since we don't have a lot of it,
Bryan Butler: And so what a model once what a question one second one say, well, they appreciate my loyalty, I feel proud sense of belonging and they believe that company employees use their own products and service, so this is, we think the the highly correlated to an emotional validation segment,
Bryan Butler: And so, these are your these are your really good customers, you want to take care of care of them, you want to know who these people are,
Bryan Butler: In the world of computer vision, I was at a conference back when we used to go to those things,
Bryan Butler: July 1 and then someone said, they should you should run your image recognition about it, your customers when they come in your bag, because you know,
Bryan Butler: they've matched the face in the balance, or something like that you can come up and say wow this person's like a really big customer, you should do something take care of them,
Bryan Butler: Interesting portrayal but you know someone would say yeah but everybody's an important customer just just another way to think about how do you take care of,
Bryan Butler: Your loyal customers and how do you show them their loyalty and that's a question 16th and important one,
Bryan Butler: And I know when we were doing this we're presenting something like this,
Bryan Butler: To some internal people,
Bryan Butler: My marketing research person use the concept of Amazon pantry and she's like just said they get it wrong all the time,
Bryan Butler: But they make it right all the time, so yeah maybe I order six things and five out of the six or right and one of them's wrong which so they always make it right, and I think that's that part of that,
Bryan Butler: How do you get you know, even if you mistake, make a mistake, how do you get people coming back to you and it's all about you know fixing years as a marketer and as a company,
Bryan Butler: So now, so when I reduce it down this is that what I said is we're going to go to a simple logistic regression, with just a couple of questions,
Bryan Butler: I lose a little bit accuracy so,
Bryan Butler: So rather than almost a perfect with only one off an air we've actually begin to make a little bit more,
Bryan Butler: False negatives or false positives here as we think they're in,
Bryan Butler: segment one where they're really not,
Bryan Butler: But we're still at 94% so we're good,
Bryan Butler: And we're not again we got to know information right so it's got good left,
Bryan Butler: We now have a happy logistic regression model for segment one,
Bryan Butler: So segment to, as I said, looking at the variable importance,
Bryan Butler: These when you answer these questions of certain way they actually pull you out of the second so you need them as a way to separate out segment one from segment two,
Bryan Butler: And if we ran this through line you'd actually see a red green or if you use the traditional college you'll see red and green scoring for these questions that they are important because they will either put you in or put push you out of the segment,
Bryan Butler: And these are different set of questions we say so, our 16th and 21 So you can see our up here not as important,
Bryan Butler: And here we're unbalanced,
Bryan Butler: And it's a mixed accuracy right so yeah we think we're really good, but most of these people are getting pushed out on the other segments,
Bryan Butler: And this is the, this is the logistic regression ball for making and that's where I said no information is 90 we're getting a little bit more left not much,
Bryan Butler: And we're making equal errors false positive false negatives,
Bryan Butler: But we definitely have these questions that are wanting to around customer service and,
Bryan Butler: that's essentially what these what these four questions, point two,
Bryan Butler: And then segment three are small one, and this is why it's hard you got some of the questions that kick you out of the segment and some of the questions that kick in the segment and there's a little bit of both,
Bryan Butler: So you think about it this way in segment one these guys were high scores, so now and segment was insane the three you're getting low scores on here, but now you're getting a different scoring across here, so these questions are pushing you in at the end of the segment,
Bryan Butler: and
Bryan Butler: The nice thing is,
Bryan Butler: We do okay at a small segment no information no information rate is 52% almost almost purely random coin toss and we're able to beat that by Thomas 30 points 78 so again I mentioned this like,
Bryan Butler: loving that 80% love to hit 85 but,
Bryan Butler: At the same time, given that it's a coin toss,
Bryan Butler: And the data set then,
Bryan Butler: That 80% we're doing Okay, and obviously,
Bryan Butler: If I use a far more sophisticated model we could probably do a little bit better, but it goes back to the constraints that customer wanted it in excel they want to be able to batch upload their own data,
Bryan Butler: And just kind of see the levers, and I think that's the other part of it, the importance of logistic regression and same thing with elastic net it's just in the logistic regression with a regularization function is that,
Bryan Butler: A business person can say yeah if I score better with this question,
Bryan Butler: i'm actually going to increase my my loyalty scores or,
Bryan Butler: You know that that's partial differential part where you say, and this is what I do when I do when I analyze service, I said look,
Bryan Butler: If you increase your score for this question by one point, the probability that they are one of your promoters, or you know frequent buyers and everything goes up by 5% and if you increased by two it goes up so it's a very,
Bryan Butler: quantitative approach to being able to say how much do I need to move the lever,
Bryan Butler: And i'll say in the NPS world, and I was doing this in my last company in healthcare um it was,
Bryan Butler: it's a lot easier to make a person go from a detractor to a neutral than it is to take a neutral person to make them a promoter,
Bryan Butler: So, as you think about ranking your your actions that you're going to take,
Bryan Butler: And so you're in this case you're dependent variables there promoter they're not and you rank the questions of importance it'll tell you what's driving in your answers,
Bryan Butler: You should focus on ones that are the low hanging fruit, but they're also easy to get them out of the detractors,
Bryan Butler: And that's what actually we did that in a couple places and it worked right like our executives actually had in their bonus plan that they had their NPS had to go up by four or five points,
Bryan Butler: And this actually created a bit of a an action plan for them,
Bryan Butler: So what do we do here, so we started out our elastic net,
Bryan Butler: We got the question we got the survey down from 17 to nine questions that's good um obviously the last event is very good,
Bryan Butler: When I looked at and I didn't show these here, but we looked at CB RC curves confusion matrix I showed you consume condition matrices just so we could get the fiesta stats out of there,
Bryan Butler: We have model free segment, these are voting approach, overall, the overall accuracy was a was over 85%,
Bryan Butler: And they said that the client said it was acceptable and they didn't have any we didn't have to come up with penalties for misclassification making a,
Bryan Butler: False positive or false name on a segment is from marker standpoint it's not the end of the world, maybe if you're spending lots and lots of money,
Bryan Butler: On something it may become more important, but in this case, it was really looking to understand what's going on within their customer segments,
Bryan Butler: And that's it,
Bryan Butler: So this so if we look at it, you can take a survey,
Bryan Butler: make a binary question out of it apply clustering maybe lead k&n better than hierarchal go or something like that i'm,
Bryan Butler: Getting get your segment labels and apply some machine learning against it, and if you get about 1000 respondents because you're seeing here, even 900,
Bryan Butler: would be reasonably accurate and you can do this to all any survey, and this is just I do this on a regular basis, over and over different service try to,
Bryan Butler: tease out some really good quantitative aspects over,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome Thank you so much, Bryan I I see there's a few questions that are starting to come in right now on Slido, but just want to let people know if you want to unmute yourself or raise your hand on on zoom you could ask questions live to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Lee I see you had asked a question earlier in the zoom chat,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): To Bryan I believe it said, do you reverse code,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): or any other item types, would you want to add any other context to that question,
Lee: Can you hear me okay yep I can,
Lee: So earlier when you were talking about item types, you talked about liquored scales and scales and all that i'm wondering if you use any reverse coding or third stone type items to make sure people just start repeatedly filling out the same value over and over when you do your assessments,
Bryan Butler: I don't like to do that, we used to have a large,
Bryan Butler: Large conversation was good, but not so much verse coding, but when it comes straight liners, which I think is what you get at know somebody,
Bryan Butler: They give everything a five or that you know, whatever it is um I look at it, I don't want to throw it out, because, especially with the light Gray scale,
Bryan Butler: it's a you don't know that could that could be a very valid data point,
Bryan Butler: 10 point scale, you said you tend to see a lot less straight what they would call a straight line,
Bryan Butler: But it's to me it's always part of the ADHD and just because we had that conversation all the time,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Bryan I can read some of the anonymous questions, but again, if you want to use slide over to you can put your name in there, and you can ask it live as well, but the first one was how the surveys conducted and collected i've noticed YouTube does surveys in between videos,
Bryan Butler: How did you do these,
Bryan Butler: The survey was done through a marketing research platform,
Bryan Butler: Our St actually most of them are done that way, so when I, so I said, this one is through marketing research platform I don't know who you are,
Bryan Butler: And you just,
Bryan Butler: plug it away, and then we get it out on the back end I think like survey monkey and something like that i've done this exact same analysis with data from survey monkey also,
Bryan Butler: That was on,
Bryan Butler: Ensure tech industry, we did about 2000 respondents from all from different groups,
Bryan Butler: And some of them are just a lot of them are generally a web based where,
Bryan Butler: You had a transaction, just like you say I need to you know hey how did you find this video you know, give us a rating one to 10 over and,
Bryan Butler: Sometimes you know you'll get a note at the end of this call you'll be asked to take a survey,
Bryan Butler: And my healthcare company I worked for had it that way too so,
Bryan Butler: which was interesting because now you're punching in numbers on a phone,
Bryan Butler: You can still do one to 10 it's just it's a little different than,
Bryan Butler: clicking a box you don't get comments as much so many you have to ask,
Bryan Butler: Good questions do have questions,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I was curious if if you don't know who is answering the survey and then you're going and making changes through the business, how do you measure like what actually made that change in the survey, or if it was like those actual,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Customers or,
Bryan Butler: Ah,
Bryan Butler: Most of them most of these types are directed at your at your customers, so you so you know your customers and in fact I did one recently at our bank,
Bryan Butler: It was a survey, and so we had all their information,
Bryan Butler: And it was actually a rerun of a service or They ran a couple you pre pandemic post pandemic once it was going on,
Bryan Butler: But it was highly skewed by the age of the responded and said,
Bryan Butler: You know you just have to point that out like you know you can actually show a slide to our presence, a look,
Bryan Butler: This is a real customer base, this is what they look like this is what I responded,
Bryan Butler: Group looks like by agent demographics, they are different they're not really speaking for our hundred percent face, but we will like one of them was to pull the pull the older segment out and then compare the different segments,
Bryan Butler: But yeah yeah so you generally try well, you want to know if their customers or not so that's that's always an intro question,
Bryan Butler: Or you know, obviously, if it's coming through your own platform,
Bryan Butler: Then you know whether they're a customer or not,
Bryan Butler: But you if you can get demographic data on people highly recommended to do it if they're if they're willing to to you know, has to just a couple questions at the end, because it can be important, just like I said with our ours is a kind of a technology based survey, so it matters,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): and a few other anonymous questions and Slido, and one is what distance metric are using are you using for the hierarchical clustering,
Bryan Butler: I use good old Euclidean distance um so think about a matrix where we have 1010 columns and we're just going to you know calculate square the distance between,
Bryan Butler: Long all those questions something it's very, very standard very clean,
Bryan Butler: And because everybody was one to 10 so I didn't have to like scale something scale them all down like, for instance, if if you're looking at web web data,
Bryan Butler: And you've got bounce rate and page views you can't do hierarchical clustering with that because pages, is going to be in the thousands and bounce rates, going to be as a percentage she'll have to,
Bryan Butler: convert those so that they're an apples to apples type metric, these are all 00 10 don't really have to do too much for that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you listen, I see you asked a great question on Slido, is it Okay, if I pass the MIC over to you to ask that,
Lucinda Linde: yeah sure that'd be good, and so I saw that you hi Bryan how you doing, first of all,
Lucinda Linde: And I saw that you were using a logistical regression for these which I think is a linear based type model,
Lucinda Linde: But I was wondering,
Lucinda Linde: If you ever tried and I know not for this one, because we can't do where to forest in excel but can can you use random forest or other ones that are that deal with nonlinear relationships well, and if you have like what have you found that there's a find other I find out other things,
Bryan Butler: I have not for this kind of stuff, but I have and what I,
Bryan Butler: What I was doing a lot of work in the insurance industry,
Bryan Butler: If you talk to actually that's all they want to do is use glm models, like some form layer
Bryan Butler: And so I showed him a standard data set of if you think about agent income right is the owner, yet you were supposed to have more income, but you often see it,
Bryan Butler: is like a a you are nonlinear almost like a bathtub where you've got people that are very young, that have a high income, then it goes down and then it goes back up and there's so many,
Bryan Butler: We see that a lot of times in the insurance industry age of a house, you know, and so the short of it is the naive bayes actually does a nice job capturing that and that was the plan is to hold up to these few I said,
Bryan Butler: here's a problem with your generalized linear model all the time and you're going to miss this every time,
Bryan Butler: Random forest is a good one too it's a little harder to explain and I think that that's where it starts to get challenging,
Lucinda Linde: In what sense is it harder to explain,
Lucinda Linde: Because, you see, you have you have the the feature importance that's how I use it, I use feature importance as my list of things to pay attention to,
Bryan Butler: yeah it is, it is so I started I like it that way, but I also try to get into this,
Bryan Butler: Because I know because they'll ask me well how much where I got to increase my score by,
Bryan Butler: And that was that's what that's when the advantage of using it linear model if you can you can always but, and I was able to say look you get the score by about five points,
Bryan Butler: you'll be much better off or you only need to actually with a lot of this stuff it's like you'll see difference between like a six and a half and a seven so like you only need to get your average up a half a point to get more people over the line,
Bryan Butler: And that's where it becomes really useful is that sort of marginal calculation, but if it's just like what do I need to fix,
Bryan Butler: Then I think, then, I agree with you 100% like especially a more accurate like you'll obviously probably be more accurate random forest bottle,
Bryan Butler: And then you can then you can just say hey This is my problem area it's pretty clear and that's what you focus on and then that's what you have no TEAM members and such experts there do,
Lucinda Linde: Okay, thank you very much, huge fan of all that you share with us,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Bryan makes us and a,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Few other anonymous ones one was how big should the sample be to get good results,
Bryan Butler: My rule of thumb is 1000, and the reason why is because i've seen some,
Bryan Butler: I remember Kelly hitting some Stat for logistic regression is like you need a minimum for one variable at 100 maybe 200 so you think about well,
Bryan Butler: we're going to have three variables i'm going to be in the five 600 range i'm going to start splitting but you know you got to be in the thousand range,
Bryan Butler: To get a get some decent results and it's come through so many times like this, this survey have 900 I did NPS with 1200 1000 1400 and i've been lucky to do surveys with 2000,
Bryan Butler: The nice thing is it doesn't take 10s of thousands, I think is a good answer but being 1000 sometimes it just may take you more time, though,
Bryan Butler: And that was a conversation I would have with leadership, and you know,
Bryan Butler: we're gonna have to run this several months so you're going to get an answer that's usable and you just have to understand, this is the, this is the rate of answers we're getting,
Bryan Butler: And we need extra mile,
Bryan Butler: And as long as you're explaining that up front, I think most people are reasonable to work with on it,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I wonder how that differs by like industry or I mean the types of surveys that people are doing and,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): curious to like hear from everybody here as well, if you want to chime in or or share info in the chat too,
Bryan Butler: So the more questions that you have, the more data you're going to need,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And someone had asked, could you clarify the survey design are we talking about three binary main questions and several one to 10,
Lucinda Linde: scale supporting machines,
Bryan Butler: know so the survey was just seven that was 1717 one to 10 questions we didn't have we didn't have a binary,
Bryan Butler: Over time, I actually got them to introduce a binary into it,
Bryan Butler: So that was why we had to do the unsupervised learning is to say,
Bryan Butler: Given these 17 questions can I find some groupings, in which case we could find three groupings that are made up by how people respond to different questions different questions, and if you see them one was customer loyalty one was,
Bryan Butler: A customer service, and I think that was emotional validation so are valued sorry value loyalty and service,
And there's,
Bryan Butler: But yeah like I always tell people,
Bryan Butler: If you're doing a generic survey, you want to know something about please have a binary question, even if I had a good experience with this company, yes, know like,
Bryan Butler: Because, then you can actually use again those questions those supporting questions or your variables to whether or not they say yes or no,
Bryan Butler: And that's why I, like you want to keep it that way,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): that's really helpful when making the model is there a difference in setting the response variable as an ordered factor or non ordered factor,
Bryan Butler: On this case it doesn't matter because it's just the binary it's the one or zero,
Bryan Butler: and
Bryan Butler: For both the elastic net package, and they are used carrot for this to back then,
Bryan Butler: It just has to be a factor it's it so you're dependent has to be a factor and that's it and it runs cleanliness is all done in our so,
Bryan Butler: I can't remember if Python requires that or not, I think it can handle a one zero as an as a standard numeric,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): A few other questions, but I did in case people have to jump at the top of the hour, I did also want to let everyone know that we've made a,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): chat marketing channel on the are for data science slack community, and so I think it's a great place to go to connect with each other to or, if you have follow up questions as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So I just want to point that out before I forget to do so, but i'll put the link to join in the chat and then the channel is just chat dash marketing,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And the backs of questions one was for bank satisfaction scores, is there a trend by Community between historic issue issues such as predatory lending practices and current satisfaction rates,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And if anyone else to add any other context feel free to jump into,
Bryan Butler: It i'll say I don't know understand for that question, but I will say,
Bryan Butler: I read a JP Morgan report out a window to come out,
Bryan Butler: December of 2020 so the end in December 2020 and it basically showed that,
Bryan Butler: Smaller regional banks had a way much higher satisfaction than the national banks and,
Bryan Butler: Part of it was due to the pandemic and that when they did the whole cares program and the loans I don't know if anybody remembers all that went up when the payment protection plan loans were coming out so that you can keep your employees,
Bryan Butler: Most of the big banks didn't you know didn't really step up for their for their customers, whereas the all the regional players,
Bryan Butler: Really jumped in and did a lot of loans, I mean my bank is quite small and reprocess almost 10,000 loans between the two programs and,
Bryan Butler: I think was a total of almost one and a half billion dollars worth, for you know small local businesses to keep their employees on the parallels and a lot of more like,
Bryan Butler: Small restaurants and small, you know just really small business getting 25,000 or 50,000 or whatever, and then the SBA once,
Bryan Butler: would forgive it and then hope around, but that was the whole cares partners that's, the only thing i've seen so satisfaction scores are generally better for smaller banks is,
Bryan Butler: The I don't have any insight into the predatory lending part of that question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks for,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Someone else that asked is your experience with survey design come from any specific texts are purely from implicit knowledge and career experience,
Bryan Butler: mostly from career experience, so I started out,
Bryan Butler: Working in a marketing research firm that I mean we would issue thousands of surveys, a year that was that was how they operated,
Bryan Butler: And what I initially found out is that,
Bryan Butler: there's leaving so much on the table, because of that, you know you get a lot of an old school marketing was what was top box, you know percentage top box bottom box, but it's like that that's not you can do better, we can do better,
Bryan Butler: So with this original original data set that the cq stuff that,
Bryan Butler: underlines underline a lot of us that created the survey and I was lucky enough, we had hundred thousand responses to work from,
Bryan Butler: This specific data set alone after we developed the cq was 900 but,
Bryan Butler: And then they kept running it so it was growing,
Bryan Butler: But it's just I think it's part of it, I bet in this marketing type of role side of the market research will do the quad shop for them created one from scratch,
Bryan Butler: And then I found that this approach i've taken out of three other places, and done the same thing, mostly around NPS modeling,
Bryan Butler: And it worked like we did the logistic regression for an insurance company and it said, you know,
Bryan Butler: there's problem ABC and that's what they did they worked on problem, and then we took the survey quarter later and problem a was now no longer problem a was it had been cured and actually the the NPS score went up three and a half points, and of course everybody's quite happy because,
Bryan Butler: You made a major KPI for your,
Bryan Butler: unit performance everybody everybody's happy then,
Bryan Butler: So it's part of it, is it just works,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): I know we just had the top of the hour, but we have two more questions if that's Okay, there you go Okay, and someone asked, do you have any go to resource recommendations,
Bryan Butler: i'm what,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'm assuming for survey design, but i'd also be curious to ask the audience here as well, if you have really helpful resources or also maybe specific packages that are helpful in the marketing space,
Bryan Butler: So I have not found a good,
Bryan Butler: A survey design text,
Bryan Butler: In fact we even had a class had a class on it marketing research and I disagreed with the instructor so that didn't really go so well,
Bryan Butler: But uh,
Bryan Butler: The first package is the clinic package out there, there is a great paper,
Bryan Butler: By rob trainee and Trevor has it on it and explains,
Bryan Butler: How it's different from original so and I think, for me, I think i've read that paper five times, just because I want to know and inside now,
Bryan Butler: This was all standard like this is simple code really that's why I didn't want to get into,
Bryan Butler: A lot of coding mean carrot glennon feel and understanding,
Bryan Butler: Of the den extend package is extremely helpful i'm i'm sort of mastered that now,
Bryan Butler: As far as being able to do it for anything like that I do it, I use that diagram for text analytics all the time,
Bryan Butler: it's been a lot of fun actually so the debt expense and package shows you how to color any which way you want size it all up flip horizontal left right,
Bryan Butler: and
Bryan Butler: I find extremely useful in text analytics visualizations when you're comparing groups,
Bryan Butler: Those are the probably the three best ones there I wish I wish I had better marketing survey information, and I think part of it is there's just not that much out there,
Bryan Butler: Which is why i've sort of created my own,
Bryan Butler: Page on what I think makes a good survey,
Bryan Butler: And I still clash with that, with people in cx all the time and they disagree with me and I, and you know that's fine that's that's what we're professionals about but,
Bryan Butler: If I if i'm going to analyze the survey and I get my say that's what I asked for,
Bryan Butler: I asked for one to 10s and I asked her binaries,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, one last question was so I guess as you're designing the survey, then, how are does surveys designed to ensure they are actually completed, for example, how many questions are too much before someone just gives up,
Bryan Butler: We found between five and 10,
Bryan Butler: and closer to five is better, so in this case, we got from 17 to nine so we got a 50% reduction,
Bryan Butler: In longer surveys you're going to have to pay people like that's just the way it is,
Bryan Butler: The insurance industry when we had to and I can't remember how much they paid for it but,
Bryan Butler: yeah after five people to get, especially for a simple like How did we do kind of thing you've only got maybe three questions before they're going to disappear on you to make, as I said, make them count don't don't make them overlap at all,
Bryan Butler: you're not trying to spot the person that's trying to game, the system, you really want to get in a short period of time how much information can you get from people,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So thank you so much, Bryan for sharing this presentation with us and just answering all those questions as well, I don't see any other that have gone unanswered, but I also just want to open it up to anybody that unmute themselves or raise your hand there's anything we've missed,